nvidia invited us to his hotel meeting
last week and i learned two important
things from the visit one you want to
sound cool when you're talking about
graphics cards you got a shortened
performance to perf it always works yeah
and two they've actually made the
desktop GTX 980 for laptops no mobile
moniker fully featured gtx 980 in
notebook form it's kind of crazy when
you think about it because when you look
at the size of a GTX card for a desktop
that thing is much larger than what
you'd imagine would fit inside of a
laptop right so I mean I'm immediately
intrigued tell me how did the perf hold
up well they had a desktop system
sitting there with a full GTX 980 and
they were running comparisons with these
laptops that were actually already
outfitted with them from from all these
manufacturers and we ran the tomb raider
benchmark you know the classic tomb
raider benchmark it rotates around her
yeah it was only like eight frames per
second slower on the laptop that's
pretty good yeah and in the everyone's
favorite shadow of mordor benchmark it
only takes like a few seconds to run
through it was the same deal like only a
little bit slower but basically on par
that's pretty crazy like I'm wondering
obviously these laptops aren't going to
be as portable even a as portable as
today's gaming laptops I mean from the
stuff I've seen so far they're pretty
bulky and that's not surprising but did
you get the sense that these are
machines that people would want to carry
around or is this sort of like a
space-saving thing that you move once in
a while you know ms i had that huge
titan laptop with the mechanical
keyboard yeah with and they're like
that's gonna have a gtx 980 in it and
that that one's huge but then there was
this this manufacturer name errores a
horas and they had really slim notebooks
actually that had this this card in it
so it's like it runs the whole gamut and
even msi had like a smaller one so i
mean it's just another basically thing
in the arsenal of these OEMs to put in
laptops and you're good to go now ace
has had this huge I'm sure you've seen
it it's like called the GX seven hundred
has this like water block on the back of
it right and they're like yeah we're
gonna sli two gtx 980 s and put it in
this thing which they didn't have
running they just had a unit to show how
like big and ridiculous it was I guess
if you can do it you might
as well do it but I'm just curious how
many people are going to make this like
a worthwhile endeavor in the end yeah
like who's gonna buy this stuff I I
don't know it's pretty neat like they
showed a Valkyrie on the new Crescent
Bay headset oculus running on a clevo
notebook which is cool like that's
running on a notebook all right and then
they showed off a three monitor like
1080p project cars you know surround
gaming setup which is like yeah right
there like showing off all the stunts
and they're doing with this card yeah um
but again like yeah what's the
practically I don't know it's just it's
just that's it it's a huge it's just
cool and you get forward really
expensive i'm assuming probably will no
more probably right as this story breaks
you know all the OEMs would be like yeah
new laptops available for sale starting
whenever yeah at this price i'll be
curious to see how this impacts the
price of gaming laptops with the mobile
variant of GPUs right be it from nvidia
or ati at this point it's gonna it has
to have an impact because if you know
once this thing comes in it's going to
disrupt the landscape yeah it's
basically a whole new way of making a
notebook there's no dip in perf
difficulty with it that's all there is
to say about this other than people
should stay tuned to our channels and
I'm sure we'll have reviews from these
notebooks as they come out yeah we'll
definitely have coverage of this stuff
down the road because this is crazy and
I'd love to see how it performs even if
I'm not writing the review myself
you